où pensez-vous que nous devrions venir
où que ce soit, juste profiter de chaque seconde passée à
sortir de Ludlow
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
[Musique] le
premier endroit où j'ai appris la mort était un
cimetière pour animaux de compagnie
[Musique] un
endroit secret
[Musique  ] de
génération en génération, des choses mortes
enterrées dans cette terre
mais revenez, il y a
autre chose
[Applaudissements]
pouvez-vous les entendre
[Musique]
Je pense que quelque chose ne va pas, continuez, il
a besoin de temps pour s'adapter
au cimetière pour animaux de compagnie bien construit pour
les protéger du mal,
ce n'est pas Timmy,
quelque chose  parler poussé par
l'étranger
[Musique]
maintenant arrête ça Je l'ai tenu le jour où il est venu
dans ce monde
la maison du jour où il sort très
bien,
crois-moi
quand je dis
[Musique]
parfois mort c'est mieux